I've got a symbol today we don't make
one up okay so I've got I wanted to talk
about Heisenberg's microscope which
comes back to the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle which we talked about in
various contexts but this is a slightly
different take on it I need to give the
brief summary as to what we have talked
about about Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle just to explain why what I'm
going to say is different the version of
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle is
basically this thing about the fact that
you can't measure the position and the
momentum of particle at same time so you
can't measure where it is and how fast
it's going both at the same time and
this is you know this is a very
well-documented phenomenon in quantum
mechanics we know that it's true it's
sort of unavoidable because it actually
follows from a mathematics follows from
the mathematics is follows from a
mathematical technique called Fourier
analysis we know that momentum is
associated with the wave length of a
wave okay and when you've got a particle
with a particular momentum that means
it's a wave which has in a very
particular wavelength to it and the only
way you can have a wave with a very
specific wavelength is if it goes on and
on forever so that's a particle which
has incredibly well-defined momentum
because it's got a wave that goes on
forever so we know exactly what its
wavelength is but we don't have a clue
where it is because the wave just goes
on and on forever so the way you can
make something more localized is what
you actually want is something like this
it's still a wave but it's kind of more
localized right it's a little bit of a
wave but it's all within some little
distance Delta X but what this technique
of Fourier analysis tells you is that
actually to make a wave look looks like
that you have to add a whole bunch of
sine waves together right the way you
make something that looks like this is
by adding waves of slightly different
wavelengths and in the middle here they
will interfere with each other in a
constructive way so they all end up
together but when you get out here
everything is interfering with
everything else and you end up with
nothing left over so the way you make
one of these little wave packets where
you've got the wave kind of restricted
in space is by adding a range of ways
together but of course each of these
waves has a slightly different wave
length which means they have a slightly
different momentum associated with it so
now although we've made the particle
nicely localized in space it no longer
has a well-defined momentum it can be
ugly you know as we know it has a
momentum that somewhere in the
associated with the range of this
wavelength the thing about this is it
doesn't actually although it looks like
you know this kind of a wavelength
associated with this is because it's not
a nice neat sine wave anymore it doesn't
actually have a single well-defined
wavelength and in fact the only way you
can define the wavelength in this is in
terms of the wavelength of all
stick to and parts so that's why it
doesn't have a well-defined labeling so
it doesn't have a well-defined momentum
and the more we squash this thing up to
make the position well-defined the wider
the range of wavelengths we have to need
to add together to make that squash
thing so the more uncertain the momentum
becomes so that is the Heisenberg
uncertainty relationship that says that
the better you measure the position
something the less well you know its
momentum or the better you define the
position of something the less well you
know it's momentum that's where we were
the classic question that gets asked in
the comment sections of YouTube videos
amongst other places is but why don't we
just do the dog job really carefully
right if we just got a particle why
don't we just measure its position in a
momentum really carefully and then we'll
know exactly where it is and we'll know
what its momentum is where we can
measure its momentum so none of this
messing around with adding waves
together let's just do the experiment as
carefully as we can actually measure the
position and momentum of a particle so
Heisenberg set up this thought
experiment called which is now generally
called the heisenberg microscope where
he thought about what's the careful it's
way that we can measure the position and
momentum of a particle so that's what he
did
what particle you're talking about here
it can be any I mean he I think he
thought about it in terms of an electron
there could be any particle you want it
really is it's because it's a very
general experiment right basically all
he did is he said here's my particle and
I'm just going to look at it and I'm
gonna look at it with a microscope so
I'm going to point a lens at it I said
because all a microscope is in crude
terms it's just the lens okay and then
I'm gonna have just a single photon of
light come along bounce off that
particle and end up going into my
microscope okay and then I'm going to
make a picture but that's just this
single photon because that's you know I
want to do this as gently as I can so I
don't want to be bombarded my particle
with lots of light I just want to touch
it as gently as I can with a single
photon so you take a picture of these
things now one of the things and other
things we actually made videos about in
the past is this this effect called
diffraction that says that actually if
you've got a lens or a mirror of finite
size you don't end up with a perfectly
pin sharp image you end up with the
image slightly blurred out through these
effects of diffraction and it's why you
know a strong one of the reasons why
astronomers like building bigger and
bigger telescopes is because the
diffraction limit gets smaller and
smaller the images get sharper which
means that if we were to look at our
particle with lots of light we wouldn't
see it as a single point right we'd
actually see it blurred out a bit just
from these effects of diffraction
even with one photon well if we've only
got one photon it's even worse than that
right because this is just
that actually if we make this image here
with lots of photons we'll see it
blurred out like that if we only see use
one photon it could be a photon arrived
here or in the middle here or over here
so actually there'll be an uncertainty
in the position just associated with the
fact that we're only detecting one
Photon
and so there's a fundamental limitation
as to how well we can measure the
position of our particle that's just due
to these diffraction effects that the
fact that that you just got a rubbish
lens
okay so let's fix the lens so that the
and we can do that right because we know
that the formula for diffraction says
that the amount this thing's blur it out
by call it Delta Theta is something like
the wavelength of the light you're using
divided by the diameter of the lens so
there's two ways we can make Delta Theta
smaller make our images sharper I think
we can use a shorter wavelength of light
like lambda smaller or we can make the
lens bigger the diameter bigger and
indeed we can do that and we can make
our images sharper and sharper just by
making the lens bigger and bigger all
using shorter and shorter wavelengths of
light however that creates a problem of
its own because let's go back to our
picture we got our particle here light
arriving and what's going to happen is
that light's going to bounce off the
particle and hit off in some other
direction and just by conservation of
momentum if the photons gone kicked off
that way then just like billiard balls
bouncing off each other if one ball goes
off that way this ball is going to
require in this direction and similarly
if it happened to a bounced off in this
direction it would have recalled in that
direction now if we make the lens bigger
whacking great lens here then actually
photons going in a very wide range of
possible directions will all end up
going through the lens because we made
the lens bigger so it's going to capture
them and because of these these photons
are now heading off in extreme
directions that means that there's
they've kind of bounced harder off the
particle here so it's going to get a
bigger kick in that direction so there's
now a bigger range of photon directions
that are going to get caught by the lens
to make our nice sharp image but because
there's a bigger range of photon
directions that means there's a bigger
uncertainty because we don't know which
direction the photon went in therefore
we don't know what direction that the
electron got kicked in we don't know how
hard it got kicked and so there's a
bigger uncertainty in the momentum of
that particle so that doesn't you know
so that's sort of that that doesn't help
us in that we get a bit or at least that
sort of illustrates the problem that we
can make the image sharper and sharper
but by making the position
no better and better by saying I've got
a really detailed picture and it's just
there suddenly the uncertainty in the
momentum of the particle gets gets
larger and so then the other thing we
can do remember is we can change the way
you've length of the photon and if we
change the wavelength of the photon
that's going to make the image sharper
but of course the wavelength of a photon
is associated with its momentum and if
we make the wavelength shorter that
makes the momentum of the photon bigger
which means it gives the electron a
bigger kick as it goes past so that also
means if it gets kicked off in some
arbitrary direction by a larger amount
and there is no way around this
trade-off between the two right if you
optimize your microscope more and more
for making the images sharper and
sharper you'll give the particle that's
being imaged a bigger and bigger kick in
some random direction and really not
know where it's going and that's so
that's the essence of this what it's a
very elegant sort of it's a thought
experiment the Heisenberg did of saying
you know I might just being stupid here
is there some clever way I could
actually measure both the position and
momentum of the particle at the same
time and it turns out you can't well why
not come up with a solution that doesn't
involve smashing it with a photon and
use it or using a lens come up with a
new way that's my problem I just think I
think you're using a blunt instrument
you know microscope is but how much how
much litt you know how much subtler can
you get I'm just using a single photon
of light and it's the minimum
disturbance I can possibly do to this
electron it's just illustrates just
illuminating it with a single photon
anything else I can do is going to be
worse than that right I've got to
illuminate it with something because
I've got to see it to know where it is
so how am I going to know where it is if
I don't see it you know your son's at
school at the moment even though you
can't see him for example like there are
there are other pieces of evidence you
can use to know information why do you
have to why do you have to see it to
believe it can't we come up with a new
way to figure out what our particles are
doing you've got to measure it right you
really got to measure it you can't just
go on faith that you know the particles
there you have got to measure it to
measure it you have to interact with it
in some way just just ask it are you
there you know and so actually this is
the subtlest way you can think of of
interacting with a particle to find out
whether it's the subtlest way Heisenberg
good think of okay so it turns out so it
turns out you touch on an interesting
point here because this was so
heisenberg came up with this thing in
1927 when people are still arguing about
whether it's right or not
people came up with his way of actually
trying to do this kind of experiment and
a couple of years ago came up with a
result which seemed to do better than
the Heisenberg relationship said you
could do